I want to know about the Dancing with
the Stars talk we are so excited we
really are pushing the limits this tour
we are getting different choreographers
we're pushing the boundaries with
ourselves and we're going to over 70
cities the longest tour to date yet we
have the most celebrities we've ever had
coming out with us which is pretty
exciting and all finalists are gonna
perform at some point what never
happened now be with all the pros in one
place for an extended period of time I'm
sure it can get a little interesting
number one who's the messiest the
biggest tour diva I would say boys so
chill pulls the most tore pranks Sasha
and also in addition to the tour you
also have Dancing with the Stars a
journey to paradise you going to the
Bahamas correct yes first time we've
ever done this we get to dance meet more
fans interact with each other it's gonna
be a really cool experience
yeah credible so if you've never been
five tickets because it's gonna be
awesome is gonna be a great company the
dancers are all gonna be there and I
think it's gonna be great some of the
most beautiful beaches that you'll ever
see there it's beautiful
[Music]